Welcome back everyone marvel just released a first
look at namor in black panther 2 so we'll break it
all down we got a reference to him during doctor
strange 2 multiverse of madness so i'll explain
that too the writer of doctor strange 2 explained
why they didn't use namor in the movie and it has
a lot to do with what's happening in black panther
too if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos we'll be getting
a black panther 2 trailer really soon too you may
see people posting about namor in all your feeds
this morning artwork of him came from the movie
marvel has also talked about the different
backstory they've created for the character
so that he won't feel like marvel's version
of aquaman just because so much of aquaman's
backstory is similar to namor's backstory even
though if you actually read the comics namor is
quite different this is a blurry potato version of
what namor is going to look like it just says his
uniform is going to be inspired by the traditional
look he does kind of look like classic namor with
the original costume they're just updating it
a little bit with modern looking technology
they're supposed to be advanced the same way
that black panther and the people of wakanda
use really advanced technology because of the
way they evolved in secrecy so what marvel has
done is they just tuned his backstory a little bit
with a couple of changes to make him fit with what
they've explained in the ancient history of the
mcu and it actually ties way back to the eternals
movie as well that's right some of the stuff they
did in the eternals movie helped set up what's
going on with modern day namor in the mcu there's
also a lot going on with the mcu gods during the
movie that will tie in with what happened during
moon knight and during thor love and thunder you'd
be surprised how many intersectional planes of
untethered consciousness exist like the ancestral
plane oh just gorgeous we literally just saw the
humanoid form of bast the panther goddess in thor
love and thunder i'll post a link to that video
in the description below there's another trailer
coming out too that we'll probably see her in in
the mcu namor and his people will be worshiping
the jaguar god so it'll be a relatively similar
backstory with the way that wakandans and black
panther worship the panther goddess these are the
details that they released about his new backstory
the character will not originate in atlantis as
in the comics but in the central american region
and will come from a historic and submerged city
of mexican culture Tenochtitlan so you get what
they're saying they're not saying that the aztec
city of Tenochtitlan was atlantis they're just
saying that namor's people came from a group
of those people all of you just watched doctor
strange 2 with scarlet witch versus the illuminati
there were a ton of cameos it was great i've done
a bunch of videos for it so i'll post all those
in the links below but a lot of you were also like
why wasn't namor part of the illuminati he was
one of the core members of the team in the comics
but it seemed like a good opportunity to introduce
the character well the writer of the movie said
that they weren't allowed to use namor like
specifically he talked about using him and
kevin feige was like no we're using him in black
panther 2. they also explained his path to the
throne of atlantis so to speak whatever they're
going to call atlantis in the mcu is similar to
black panther's path in the mcu they're trying to
create some similarities between their characters
so when the movie picks up it sounds like namor
will have been the prince of his city like his
parents will still be alive the king and queen
the same way that when captain america civil war
picked up black panther's father t'chaka was still
alive but he had already become black panther and
gotten his powers it sounds like something is
going to happen and eventually he will be forced
to take the throne and that'll be involved in the
big beef in the mcu between their characters like
remember what happened with black panther during
captain america civil war when he became king
after his father had been assassinated so they're
trying to give reasons why namor would be such an
inside the mcu and why he would go after black
panther this at namor will be an important part
of the film and will ask wakanda for help to keep
his people hidden from humans as the world starts
to learn about the existence of his version of
atlantis because of a new technology created by
riri williams ironheart while she's still in
school at mit so that also explains why riri
williams is in this film to begin with because
in the comics she doesn't really have anything
to do with wakanda they are doing an iron
heart series in an iron man armor war series
it also sounds like while she's tinkering with
creating this new version of armor that they'll
eventually debut in the iron heart series some
part of that new technology accidentally reveals
the existence of atlantis it sounds like it'll
be one of those accidental things at the start
that'll spin up into chaos and cause full-blown
war between their peoples it's kind of the way
that baron zemo tried to manipulate events to
push the avengers to eventually break apart
like winter soldier had done a lot of bad things
they weren't lying about that he was an actual
criminal but baron zemo tried to play on those
circumstances to push the avengers to fight with
each other eventually and cause this giant war it
sounds like it'll be a similar situation during
black panther too even though it sounds like namor
is trying to protect his people and wants to go to
black panther for help and they don't really want
to get involved with that and that leads them to
go to war with each other eventually his name was
trying to protect his people or thinks that he's
protecting his people it sounds like neither one
of those groups will be responsible for starting
things like somebody behind the scenes will try
to spin things up into a greater chaos reading
on those tremors it was a mild subduction under
the african plate do we have a visual how are we
handling it nat it's an earthquake under the ocean
we handle it by not handling it i know everybody
would love to see a version of dr doom debut in
the mcu but just seems like there's too much going
on in this film for them to introduce doctor doom
on top of all this it does say though that during
the movie they will debut wakanda's navy for
the first time like they have an actual naval
force that's more capable of fighting underwater
some of those ships that they already use during
the movie are more suited for atmospheric flight
but they can be modified for deep space flight as
confirmed during the what if series but there's a
whole lot to unpack here first thing mutants namor
is called the first mutant in the comics because
he was the actual first character literally in
marvel comics they debuted as a mutant that was in
1939 apocalypse celine who are also mutants that
debuted earlier in the timeline in the context
of the universe weren't actually created in real
life till much later if you're going by actual
debut though technically scarlet witch would
be one of our first mutants in the mcu like
she and quicksilver were already canonized as
mutants billy and tommy are also mutants in the
mcu and now after doctor strange ii multiverse
of madness it seems like marvel is really just
using the multiverse to introduce most of the
mutants to the mcu from the legacy fox x-men
universe you thought i was asleep didn't you
acting but we'll probably see mutants show
up from a couple different sources like some
will show up in universe because of events that
have happened and some of them will come from
the multiverse it sounds like he's gonna be
close to black panther's eighth to t'challa's
age and he'll have similar circumstances that
t'challa had when he took the throne eventually
he was forced to lead his people after his
father had been assassinated it sounds like
something might happen to namor's parents during
this film too the whole subplot tying them to the
eternals movie is them coming from the central
american aztec mexican culture in Tenochtitlan
so some of their backstories trying to play on
real world mythology about what actually happened
to the aztec culture because they were this highly
advanced people in real life the way they set up
the atlanteans during the turtles movie is that
basically namor's people come from the same group
of aztecs who eventually left this city when it
fell to ruin they have this advanced culture the
eternals are living amongst them everything seems
like it's fine they're meant to be advanced kind
of like the wakandans are during this period
in history later in the timeline the spanish
conquistadors start invading killing them up
this is what causes the eternals to break up
the first time because they want to help them
but ajax is still towing the line for airship
the judge the other celestials trying to help
tiamat grow faster get to the emergence faster
so druid leaves with a small group of the aztecs
not all the ones that survive but some of them
they form a community deep in the rain forest
that druid uses his powers to keep hidden from
the rest of the world for a couple thousand years
until present day those are not meant to be the
atlanteans the group of aztecs that namor would
have come from in the mcu sounds like they were
part of that original group that left the city but
was separate from druid like as the conquistador
started invading a completely different group
of them broke off and created atlantis and then
just rose up in hiding the same with wakanda rose
up and their technology evolved without having to
worry about words with other cultures but now
you see the similarity between namor's people
and black panthers people like during the black
panther backstory in the mcu knowledge of wakanda
their way of life had been threatened by the
rest of the world until black panther stepped in
and eventually found some sort of compromise the
only difference in the comics is that namor is a
way bigger than black panther the whole thing with
namor and his people worshiping the jaguar god
also dovetails with this mcu backstory we
saw in moon knight and now in thor love and
thunder with all the gods like this is bast the
panther goddess or at least her humanoid form
most the time in the comics the way they depict
her is like this humanoid looking panther the
way that you see the hippo goddess walking around
like a hippo on two legs oh gosh this will really
bake your noodle but i think you were just taking
a little time out i'm afraid you're actually quite
dead the whole thing with black panther his powers
in the panther goddess is that he has a contract
with her but he's not meant to be her avatar the
same way that moon knight is the avatar of khonshu
like moon knight is kind of the slave of khonshu
black panther forms more of a regular contract
with bast the panther goddess she's more of
a benevolent god but she doesn't step in to
help them with every single little thing she
usually just leaves them to their own devices
it sounds like namor is going to have the
same type of relationship with the jaguar god
so that would explain how he's able to go toe
to toe with black panther and why he potentially
might wind up killing him because they do have to
explain chadwick boson's passing they did say that
they would address that during the movie i know
there's a lot of questions about what's going on
with the next version of black panther because
the mantle will eventually be passed there's a
version of shuri who becomes black panther in
the comics there's also rumors about umbaku in
the mcu becoming the next black panther so when
we get some more details about how all this is
connected of course i'll do a video and my brand
new thor love and thunder trailer video we'll post
next so make sure you have alerts enabled for my
channel so you don't miss that everyone click here
for that thor love and thunder trailer video i'll
update the link as soon as i post it and click
it for my new fantastic four video about how reed
richards knew about kang the conqueror in the mcu
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!